Hello everyone. Thanks so much for
joining me today. Let me start by asking
you a very simple but profound question.
What happened when the smartest tool we
have ever built stop working for us and
start working against
us? Let's just stop for a moment and
think about it.
Imagine getting a phone call. A voice
sounds exactly like your manager. The
same tone, the urgency, the choice of
word, everything on the spot. He says
his intranet is down and asks you to
urgently send all the confidential
information to his personal email so
that he can brief a client.
It all seems legitimate until you later
discover it was a deep fake scam. You
unknowingly sent company sensitive
information to a
frosture. Or picture this, a face appear
on your screen for a video KYC, blinks
at the right time, smiles naturally,
clears identification without a hitch.
But here is the catch. It's not real.
It's AI generated deep
fake. We all know it already. So the
issue is we are not dealing with old
school fraud anymore. We are facing
synthetic
identities, deep fake onboarding and
AIdriven scams that look and feel more
human than human itself.
These threats do not just break in, they
get verified and walk through the front
door completely
undetected. The issue is we are not just
trying to detect fraud now. We are
trying to detect
intelligence and that's the real
challenge and it is exactly why we need
to rethink everything we know about
trust identity defense in the age of
AI. So how do we fight back?
How do we stay ahead in the world where
fraud does not just hide, it blends
in? This is where cognitive shields
comes in. Today I will show you how our
cuttingedge solution leverages advanced
AI and machine learning to spot and stop
these invisible threads.
But before we dive in, let's start with
some real
stories. Here are three real life
stories that highlight how AIdriven
fraud is affecting people today.
The first story is a story of Anthony
and this story is about voice cloning
scam. Let's let's let's listen to it.
Anthony is a retired father lives in
California. One afternoon he got a phone
call. The voice on the line undeniably
his sons. Same accent, same little tone
only a father would
recognize. The son sounded panicked.
There has been a terrible accident. A
pregnant woman was hurt and he was at a
police station and needed bail money
immediately.
A moment later, another man called and
he claimed to be his son's lawyer and he
urged Anthony to wire
$50,000 immediately or his sons would be
taken to
jail. Anthony has never heard about deep
fake, but he heard heard about his son's
voice and he trusted it.
He immediately wired 50,000 his entire
retirement saving later to know it
wasn't his
son. It was a AI generated voice clone
created using publicly available Tik Tok
video of his
son. This time when by the time the real
son came in the evening the money was
already
gone. Uh let me let's listen to second
story and this story is about Lisa a 45
year woman who lives in Ohio. She feels
very isolated more
isolated after
pandemic. One night a man messaged her
or her Instagram claiming to be a famous
Australian TV star. He called her her
his soulmate and promised to marry
her. And this continues for over 18
months. They message every day but never
met, always blaming visa and money
issues. He asked for
help and Lisa sent nearly 40,000 of her
savings over time.
But the man wasn't real. His face was
made by AI and this was a scam. These
scams actually has a name and this is
called pig butchering and are growing
very fast. Scammer in this case build
fake relationship to steal money often
using AI and crypto to hide their track.
and Lisa reported it in January 2025 and
she shared her story to warn others and
she feels if it is too perfect to be
true it might be a
scam. Let's talk about third and the
last story and this is the story of
Xavier.
Xavier is a 25 29-year-old accountant
from Austin, Texas. He's really
smart, financially savvy, and always on
a look for a real big tech opportunity.
He thought he found one in early
2025. And that's when he discovered
ZipMax Pro, a flashy new cryptocurrency
project that seems to check all the
right
boxes. It had
everything. A very slick
professionallook website, dozen of
growing investor testimonials on
YouTube, white paper filled with current
cuttingedge AI and blockchain
jarens, an active Discord channel run by
charismatic
developers, weekly live stream and AMAs
featuring synthetic avatar modeled after
real silicon. Valley
influencers and even deep fake video of
Elon Musk appearing to endorse the
project. And the pitch was very
simple. A
AIdriven platform that optimize defy
investment and promising up to 35%
annual return.
Xavier like thousands of other believed
he was getting in very early to this
next big thing. He invested 60,000 of
his personal savings and entire
401k. Then without warning it all
disappeared one day. The creator of Zip
ZipMax Pro executed a classic
rugpull, dumping their holdings,
crashing the coin value to
plummet. Xavier lost everything. But he
wasn't alone. Over 5,000 people across
the US were defraed by the same scam.
And the worst part, every element of the
scam was powered by AI. Fake ID uh ID
verification to pass the crypto exchange
check, defake celebrity endorsements, AI
written smart contract that looked
legitimate, social media bought and
synthetic influencers to build hype.
This wasn't just a isolated incident. AI
powered scam have surged
375% since
2023. 76% of synthetic identities now
bypass traditional fraud
detection. Americans reported record
$9.3 billion in losses from cryp
cryptoreated crime. And this is 66% just
uh jump in just one
year. These are not fishing emails of
the
past. They are intelligent emotionally
engineered attack built by machine and
designed to exploit trust at
scale. As AI continues to evolve, so do
the tools of frosters.
So it's imperative that we develop a
robust defense to protect individual
from such sophisticated
scam. So now let's be honest, AI can be
used to deceive, to defraud, to
exploit. But here is a good news. AI can
also be used to detect, to defend and
protect. And that's the paradox we are
living in. It is the one we have to
embrace. The same AI that is used to
commit fraud can be trained to stop
fraud. The same model designed to
manipulate behavior can be retrained to
re recognize it and shut it down. The
same technology that is shaking our
foundation of trust, it can be reused to
rebuild trust and is stronger than ever.
And in this presentation, I'm going to
show you exactly
how. So now that we have laid out the
challenges and the high stake of
AIdriven fraud, it's time to talk about
the solution.
Let me introduce you to Cognitive
Shield, the next generation platform
designed specifically to protect
financial financial ecosystem against
this sophisticated
threat. Cognitive Shield is designed as
a simple threelayer defense system.
Each layer is tackling a different part
of the fraud problem from prevention of
real time detection all the way to
intelligence
response. The layer one is all about
building a strong foundation.
This is where we securely manage user
data, licensing data, examination,
cases, and payment data. But it's it's
but it's more than just a storage layer.
We use AI to guide user through the
complex processes and flag potential
risk before they become real problem.
It is safe, it is smart and it is user
friendly. Next come the layer two. In
layer two is about realtime fraud
detection engine. This is where AI
really shines.
Our system uses eight advanced detection
module
constantly scanning for threat for deep
deep fake bot fishing attacks, synthetic
identities, crypto scam and more.
We also use graph technology to map user
and transsectional behavior helping to
spot the fraud rings that traditional
system usually
misses. Finally,
layer three brings all the things
together by combining AI and human
insights for a smarter response.
Investigator get powerful console with
AI powered search and live dashboard and
trend
analysis. Cases are automatically
escalated when needed and the system
keep complete audit trail of
compliance. This means teams can move
faster, stay organized and meet
regulatory demand effortlessly.
In
short, Cognitive Shield brings together
smart secure data
management, realtime AI detection and
intelligent human-led
responses all in one platform so that
the organization can stay ahead of fraud
every step of way.
Let's start with layer one, the
foundation of cognitive shield, our
secure, user and regulatory management
layer. This is where all the core
operations happen. The licensing,
application,
examination, case tracking, payment,
etc.
It is built on secure reliable database
so that your data stays protected and
organized. But what really set this
layer apart is that how deeply AI is
integrated into every step of the
process. For example, when a user
submits a license application or renew
AI or a renewal application, AI
instantly check for missing information,
flag
inconsistencies and offer realtime
guidance. It is like having an expert
watching over every form and making the
processes smoother and error-free.
When agencies launches exam AI reviewer
response response and document to spot
unusual pattern potential red flags
helping teams focus only where human
attention is really
needed on the legal and billing side. AI
breaks down the complex cases, outcomes,
clarifies fines and deadlines, answers
any user questions in plain and everyday
language. No more digging into legal
legal legal jarens anymore.
It also has a smart built-in assistant
that user can use to ask ask question
naturally, upload legal document, get
quick summaries, insights all in one
place. And finally, everything is
presented in a roles specific dashboard.
Whether you are a regulator, a licenser,
a auditor, you get a clear view of the
application compliance status and
payment workflow. So layer layer one
isn't about managing data. It's about
turning the complex processes into
seamless intelligent experience.
Now let's delve into layer two, the core
of cognitive shield system. This layer
is engineered to identify and mitigate
sophisticated fraud attempts in real
time leveraging state-of-the-art AI
technologies.
Our system comprises of eight
specialized detection module each
tailored to identify a specific type of
fraudulent
activity. Deep fake detection for
example utilizes generative adversarial
network GANbased system to identify and
manu manipul man manipulate media.
Bot detection for example employs
machine learning
classifier gradient boosting machine to
discern automated bot activities in
blockchain
transaction. Fishing detection analyzes
the communication pattern using natural
language processing to detect AI
generated fishing attempts uses who is
and other techniques.
Crypto scam generation applies graph
neural network to analyze transaction
network identify anomalies
patterns and in the fraudulent
activities to power our fraud detection
engine. We use some of the most advanced
AI technologies that are built to
understand and respond in real time.
For example, we use deep learning that
help us analyze
images, audio to detect things like deep
fake, voice cloning quickly and
accurately. Graph neural network tracks
connections between user devices
transaction spotting hidden fraud rings
and a suspicious pattern that we miss
otherwise.
natural language processing, reads and
interpret text to detect the fishing
attack attempts, social injuring tricks,
unusual language and communication, etc.
And we finally have a multimodal signal
processing that pulls all together in
the text, voice, metadata. We get a full
picture of the thread and the and we can
respond respond smartly.
Let's talk about how we use graph
powered AI to find hidden
fraud. Fraud is not
always one bad actor. It is often
network of connected people, account and
devices. So that we have to we have to
focus on how things are connected not
just what
happened and here is how we do it in
three simple step. Step one is building
the graph. One of the hardest part of
graphbased fraud detection is turning
the unstructured data into a structured
graphical for knowledge
base and we solve this using agenting
workflow that we built using crew AI and
large language model.
They here we can uh we can extract the
entities and relationship from simple
text, PDF, document, forms, emails, logs
and etc.
We also enrich these graphs with
information from the internal Postgress
database that help us tie everything
together to create the complete realtime
view of the fraud landscape.
Then we run models like GNN to find the
hidden connection things like group of
accounts that are acting in in sync
devices that that has been reused across
the multiple fake identities and so on.
In short, we have automated the most
difficult part of the graph intelligence
that is creating the knowledge graph and
we turned it into a powerful tool for
uncovering fraud rings that would
otherwise stay
hidden. Step two is
Neoforj is used as a graph persistent
mechanism.
We store all the graphs and uh nodes and
relationship into a Neo4j open graph
database. And step three is asking graph
smart questions. And this we do by using
Neo4j based uh retrieval augmented
generation or rack system that integrate
it with large language model to convert
to take the user queries in natural
language and then translate that into a
cipher uh language that is understood by
Neo4j and and and that allows input
that allows us to
generate u generate user um user queries
in seamlessly by taking in in the
natural language.
This setup enables realtime exploitation
of graph relationship supporting high
performance fraud detection by surfacing
patterns, anomalies and entities,
linkages that traditional relational
system often underlook.
So let's talk about layer three and this
is where everything comes
together. As fraud become more advanced,
our response need to be smarter, faster
and more
coordinated. This layer is all about
that turning alerts into action and
action into result.
So first step is the unified fraud
intelligence console. Think of this as a
mission control. It brings the insights
from across the system into one place.
And the best part is it uses AI powered
natural language search to
investigate so that user do not need to
remember complex queries to get the
insights from the data whether it is
Postgress database or Neoforj
database. Second step second uh step is
real time dashboard and adaptive
analytics. This dashboard give us the
live view of what is happening. Fraud,
hotspots, trending uh tactics, big
actors are connected. It is the it's
where you you will see the visual
intelligence that helps terms that helps
teams move faster and make more most
informed decisions by looking into these
dashboard uh in real time.
Then we have a case escalation system or
alert and and also alerting system. And
what it does it it it it spots the
serious threat. It does not just flat
get it acts on it. Also AI automatically
analyzes how severe the open case is
routed to the right person or the team.
It uses the mix of rulebased and LLM
based logic to decide what needs more
attention and when and everything is
logged with role based access and full
audit
trail. Finally, we have compliance ready
reporting. All investigators are
investigations are fully traceable.
Reports can be exported in PDF or in CSV
form and these helps
regulators, auditors and internal team
everything is clear, well document and
easy to
share. So in short layer three is where
insights become action. It helps you
detect, respond, escalate, and report
all in real time and all with complete
transparency. Before we get into the
architecture of the system, let's let's
stop here and let's see how now you have
the background. Let's see how the real
system looks like.
I will give you a walk through of this
is the cognitive shield uh
application. Here you see the cognitive
shield. This is the main dashboard where
you see what are the re recent searches,
what are the emerging thread, what are
the re what are the recent
alerts and and and as we mentioned
before this is a three layer system.
Layer one is about user management.
Layer two is about fraud detection and
and also about graph fraud detection and
layer three is about investigations and
search and dashboarding alerting and so
on. So we start with user management.
This is where the user activities are
recorded. Security setting is done. User
account management, user contact
management, everything re related to the
user is is is performed in this flow.
Then we have the case management. In the
case management, you can create a case,
you can analyze the case using AI, you
can search for cases and so on. Then we
have examination management. Here we any
cases all this you can look at the
scheduled exam all in progress exam
completed exam canceled exam there is a
you can create a
start examination on any cases you can
manage existing exam you can perform
risk risk assessment risk history
business rules you can also view
the timing of the system. You can view
the expense report, billing thing,
analysis, all kind of analytics and
reporting. Then we have invoice
management system. Every system as you
see all flows starts with a dashboard
where you see the summary of what what
you have done. The here you have um
invoices invoices that are draft, sent,
paid, overdue, cancelled. You can create
a new new invoice. You can export the
invoice. You can get the AI analysis of
the
invoice. Then we have a processing flow.
Here you can link different
organization. You can form you can
perform the calculation. You can get the
disc discrepancy detection using AI. We
have payment portal. In this payment
portal, you can see the pending payment,
payment history, different kind of
receipt and so on. Then we have a chat
um chat assistant. This is a multimodal
chat assistant that is ba based on voice
output, voice input, web search,
different mode modality of search. Here
you can browse and and save user data
that you want to search on and so
on. Then we have a different kind of
fraud detection system. You can perform
a deep fake fraud detection and in this
case you can perform a deep fake fraud
on images, videos, audios and and you
can get the uh recent analysis. You can
search by different uh deep fake uh
fraud. There is a threat intelligence
and so on. Then we have a payment fraud.
What kind of suspicious transaction
observed? What kind of active cases?
What kind of a response time you can you
can see you can see the fraud trend over
time fraud by different types alert
statistics also the payment analysis
using AI fraud pattern observed
different case
management. Then we have a web fraud.
This these are the real time fraud
monitoring. Then we have social media
fraud. Here you can choose the different
social media that from where you
different fraud type the investment
scan, fishing
scan,
and crypto scam and so on observed on
different fraud uh different social
media. Then we have cryptocurrency
currency fraud. This is u you can you
can get the suspicious crypto wallet
smart contract transactional flow sus
you can watch the suspicious activity in
blockchain financial impact by different
blockchain cryptocurrency schemes fraud
trend and so on. Then we have fishing
detection. Uh uh what are the different
uh active fishing campaign going on?
Domain analysis. What are the targeted
organizations? And then we have bot
detection. What are the different bot
network bot behavior threat
analytics and and so on.
Similar we also have graphbased fraud
detection knowledge graph builder. Here
you connect to the
Neo4j. We have text to graph. It helps
you create the knowledge graph based on
the user
text. You can create the graph based on
on the PDF document or um or or document
file. and and then we have a query
generator that can generate a cipher
query based on your user natural
language and we have a graph rag to
extract the query and get the
insights. Similarly, we have uh advanc
we have in investigation and
enforcement. This is where user can
perform the searches, general searches,
domain regulation, monitoring and you
can also have a search history. You have
analytics dashboard of the whole system.
Um and also you can get the AI insights
uh from also the transaction and
alerting system, fraud pattern,
geographic distribution of the threads,
risk risk model performance. We have
alert monitoring.
Uh here you can choose the se severity
of the attack, the status of attack and
the sources where you want to filter the
attacks and and and get the dashboard.
Um it also saves your attacks uh and and
statistics and you can perform the
active investigations on different uh
frauds and so on.
So this is basically a very high level
what we have uh uh what what we have
done and we also have different uh here
are the APIs that we have designed to uh
it's a APIdriven architecture where APIs
are are designed and used to extract the
data and manage
um and and and extract ract the data and
and manage uh from the front
end. So coming back to our
system. So let's let's learn about how
we have actually built this uh uh this
this system. Cognitive shield is just
not another fraud tool. It's a real
smart AI enabled AI supported tool that
handles the modern fraud from defake to
crypto scam to social engineering and so
on. The front end we have built using a
streamlit to create easy to use realtime
dashboard.
API layer is built using fast API that
handles all the incoming data whether it
is the login transaction document upload
and so
on. AI layer is powered by uh crew AI
that is the brain of the system. It runs
multiple AI agents that work together
um and and and get the insights.
The data layer is done in Postgress
database. Neo4j is using for graph
analysis and then we have graph rag rag
and lang chain for AI
agents.
So the whole system is designed to build
and and scale a real realtime detection
of the different frauds.
This is AI fraud defense which is a
smart, fast and built for today's
threats. Let's let's
let's talk about what we have really
learned after building this this system.
We learned that if you build a system,
we have to
start with security from day one. Trust
is not something you patch in later. It
has to be ingrained into the
system. Next, do not rely on single AI
model to catch all kind of
fraud or all kind of fraud. Fraud is a
messy fast changing. So one size is not
going to fit all kind of fraud
problem. So we have to use multiple
specialized agent. Each one turn from
specific task and let them collaborate
um in a agentic manner. Then always
think in graph not just rows and and and
columns of a relational database. graph
help us detect the hidden connections
which we usually miss in the relational
database and and instead of building a
giant monolithic system, think of
microservices and we used fast API
APIdriven architecture that can be
easily
scaled and we have to keep observability
in mind. We have to monitor the AI
models like um uh we have to monitor the
uptime, we have to monitor the false
positive, false negative, we have to
track everything and we have to make
sure that every decision is
explainable and that is how we earn
trust. Finally, build the privacy from
this chart. We encrypted everything. We
assumed nothing. And with these
principle we made cognitive shield a
resilient, transparent and build for
real world of financial fraud.
As we close today's
presentation, let's try to
summarize and bring everything
together. We have learned that cognitive
shield is built by three-step system.
Step one is about data trust, data
storage and everything is start by
keeping the privacy of the user, user
security and also using AI to help the
user manage and say and and and store
the data. Step two is a real time fraud
detection. This is the brain in action
powered by deep learning, graph AI,
secure LLM that do not just react to
fraud. They anticipate it and and and
and work on
it. Step three is intelligence hub for
responses and compliance. This is where
the insights become action. We surface
the signals, the alerts, the visual
dashboard and compliance
reporting. Here is what the cre takeaway
is that AI is not an optional tool is
the future for future of fraud defense.
Graph over
tables because is essential because
relationship revealed by relational
database has to be also supported by
graph to capture the network of
connections.
Multi-agent LLMs give us the speed,
clarity and context of the word where
millisecond
matter. Why do we have to act now?
Because if we wait by
2027 90% of cyber attack will be
AIdriven. Fraud losses will surpass $100
billion per year.
So we cannot wait because our mission is
very clear. We have to stop fraud before
it start. This is not just a platform.
It is just a
technical it is a movement and we want
you to be part of it.
Let's defend trust. Let's protect the
future. And let's do it all
together. As we wrap up this
presentation, I want to take a moment to
dedicate this presentation to someone
who has been a true inspiration in my
journey. Jeremy Howard, the visionary
behind Fast.AI.
AI. He did not just teach me how to
build models. Everything I know about
deep learning, I learned from his
classes, his code, his belief that AI
should be open, ethical, and accessible
to
all. His work changed the field of AI. U
you ulm fit redefined how we approach
NLP.
But more important his teaching changed
people including
myself. This platform this mission this
entire journey is buil built on what you
gave us all. Thank you so much Jeremy
for your vision, generosity, courage and
continue to inspire us all. Thank you so
much everybody. Thanks